good morning Hank it's Wednesday
suddenly and unexpectedly it has become
spring so I thought I'd take you on my
favorite walk today while I answer real
questions from real nerdfighters how do
I know if I love him
well for one thing you don't generally
find yourself asking that question who
the eff is Hank Hank is a small coral
atoll 700 3 nautical miles south of the
Equator
Hank is known as one of the most remote
uninhabited islands in the world you
have any beard growing tips uh I mean I
guess the main tip would be just try to
avoid shaving that's really in the end
what takes down almost a hundred percent
of beards shaving ah we have arrived
Hank right here in suburban Indianapolis
nature when he coming out with a new
book my new book which I co-wrote with
my friend David Levithan is called Will
Grayson Will Grayson and it comes out in
28 days wait hold on a second I have a
book coming out in 28 days French the
llama are you going on tour yes I will
be in Indianapolis on March 15th talking
about vlogging and then in April I will
be in Chicago Boulder Austin Texas New
York City Madison Connecticut LA and San
Francisco more info in the doobly-doo I
pointed in the wrong direction ha ha
will you give away some advance reading
copies of will Grayson Will Grayson -
nerdfighters yeah that's a great idea I
have five advanced readers copies of
Will Grayson Will Grayson at home I will
give all of them away to a random
commenter here or at the Ning how's the
diet the diet still going well but one
thing I wanted to mention I'm not
actually losing weight because people
were shaming me in fact I think shaming
is always inappropriate and it's a
particularly bad motivator the whole
idea of the John Green is that did it
was to talk about why it's so enjoyable
to have fun at other peoples expense but
then it just got muddled and confusing
and I'm sorry the reason I'm losing
weight is because of a Henry like I look
at him and I think well I guess the only
real motivator in this world is love
well and also wanting to make your
ex-girlfriends regret dumping you yes
true also that if you were in a band
what would you call it I would
definitely still call it mo and the
lawns or the Moby moby-dick tones how is
a raven like a writing-desk peg that is
a trick and I am NOT going to fall for
it Lewis Carroll intended that riddle to
have no answer but what does a
writing-desk have in common with a raven
hmm ah I got it Edgar Allan Poe
out on both riddle even when you don't
have a solution I can pone you what part
of VidCon are you looking forward to the
most I can't pick just one I'm gonna
pick fors a Frank the ball pit Charlie
McDonnell biting my finger and the
awesome concerts at night are you and
Hank trying to get rich from VidCon
yeah Hank and I were sitting around one
day and we thought to ourselves how
could we get rich maybe a YouTube
conference no any proceeds from VidCon
are gonna go to charity and one other
thing I should tell you you can get a
full refund until June 15th and for some
reason you can't go and if you don't
know what VidCon is there's a link in
the doobly-doo but I'm not going to
humiliate myself by pointing in the
wrong direction again will I become
incredibly sympathetic to the homosexual
agenda after reading Will Grayson Will
Grayson well I have to say that as a
writer I don't really aspire to be in
the agenda sympathizing business I
aspire to be in the telling good and
true stories business why don't you and
Hank do challenges anymore I don't know
Hank let's do some challenges I'll see
you on Friday
see what happened Hank I was trying to
give you a fun video outside and then I
cut myself on nature stupid nature